Carved by the classical sculptor Phidias in 435 B.C.,...
...the Statue of Zeus sat in the ancient town of Olympia, Greece.
A simple temple did not seem good enough for the King of Gods, Zeus, so this statue was built.
It stood 40 feet tall, and Zeus sat on a throne of cedar wood...
...and in his right hand was a small statue of Nike, the goddess of victory.
It now attracted tourists from all over the world.
It is at debate how the statue was destroyed.
Some say it remained in the temple until the 5th century A.D. when the temple was destroyed,...
...while others say it was carried away to Constantinople where it was destroyed in a fire.
However, in 1958, the workshop of the Statue of Zeus was discovered...
...and here, many secrets into the building of the statue were also found out.